gérard filoche bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors si
la réforme des retraites a été suspendue
du fait de la crise sanitaire liée aux
commis 19
il n'a jamais été question pour le
gouvernement de l'enterrer complètement
est ce que vous êtes surpris
et bien c'est bien dommage parce qu'il
ya beaucoup plus à faire que de nous
casser les pieds nouveau avec cette
réforme mal fagotée qui n'avait même pas
réussi à faire passer et négocier et
comprendre je rappelle de 70% d'opinions
et elle contre et je rappelle que cette
réforme était argumenté selon des
critères qui aujourd'hui semble bien
dépasser sinon désolé on des élus quels
sont ces critères dépasser pour vous
gérard filoche sait que le contexte
économique qui a changé mais qu'il
voulait que la les retraites ne coûte
pas plus de 14% du produit intérieur
brut
maintenant il le produit intérieur brut
semblerait avoir baissé de 10 à 12%
c'est que les gens imaginent ce que ça
veut dire pour leur retraite avec une
baisse du produit intérieur brut
répercuter en pourcentage ça n'est plus
14% de 100% c'est 14% de 88%
c'est un vrai tassement c'était une
tuerie contre les retraites
ensuite jouer maintenant monsieur le
maire qui dit pour augmenter les lâches
dès le départ parce qu'on vit plus
longtemps en est-on sûr parce que je
crois comprendre qu'on est menacé par
une nouvelle pandémie où l'espérance de
vie elle même est aujourd'hui menacée et
donc ils sont bien tranquilles de nous
parler pour dans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans 30
ans sans prendre les mesures aujourd'hui
pour confus pour payer nos retraites
il suffirait d'augmenter les cotisations
sociales de 0,1 point 2.3.2 façon à
garder la prestation en ajustant les
cotisations ou ensuite après on nous dit
alors là j'entends des choses
extraordinaires la clause du grand père
justement se seraient ceux qui sont nés
à partir de 2004 qui vers 2000 65 66 67
on ne sait pas trop bien qui verrait le
mauvais système par points s'abattre sur
eux alors là l'argument avant c'était
dire il faut toucher la retraite vite
maintenant pour protéger celle de nos
enfants
mais attention tout ce qu elle nous
retraite maintenant ce seront nos petits
enfants qui vont la payer
alors parce que effectivement gérard
filoche d'après la note
elle précise que cette clause du
grand-père intégral pourrait faire
l'objet je cite d'une plus grande
acceptabilité sociale se serait établie
par sûr vous ne s'en seraient pas
concernés mais allons nous accepter de
laisser nos enfants pays à notre place
allons nous les chinois jeu quand je
vois ma petite fille judith est né en
2004 basse et toi tu as plus de retraite
ma vieille si je ne bouge pas tout de
suite tu n'as plus de retraite
alors pour l'instant à la 15 ans elle
est allée pas tout à fait motivé mais
elle peut comprendre que si j'accepte la
cause du grand-père de ce foutu
gouvernement macron castex et bien
tourelles c'est foutu alors évidemment
c'est un dollar c'est acceptable comme
ils disent cissé il faut attendre 60 ans
pour que le mal vous tombe sur la tête
par contre ils protègent des policiers
de ce mal parce qu' il n'est pas
question chez monsieur qu'accepte
qu'elle est que sa première priorité en
tant que chef du gouvernement c'était la
police il n'est pas question de toucher
aux à la retraite des policiers on voit
bien de quoi il s'agit c'est toucher à
la retraite des pouvoirs des soignants
des caissières de tout ce qu'on fait
vivre la france dans les six derniers
mois et de ne pas toucher la retraite
aux policiers et de reporter sa sourde
aux petits enfants dans 60 ans ou 50 ans
ils s'établiront et du square à l'essai
pour des d'argent parce que gérard
filoche ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est que d'après la note
la clause du grand-père intégral bon
effectivement il y aura une plus grande
acceptable acceptabilité sociale mais
selon les auteurs de la note cela
enverrait le signal d'un gouvernement
qui a reculé mais toute façon ce
gouvernement reculera qu'il le comprenne
au lieu de s'entêter et d'autre part le
mot acceptabilité humain digne
ça veut dire en fait capituler en
repoussant sa sur nos enfants on peut
pas accepter ça personne peut accepter
ça et donc alors après on nous dit oui
mais on va augmenter l'âge de départ en
retraite
mais en ce moment c'est plutôt l'emploi
qu'il faut augmenter et il place aux
jeunes
place aux jeunes parce que si c'est 63
64 c'est les jeunes qui ont moins de
boulot surtout en ce moment boulot
sorhaitz klein ce qu'il faut c'est pas
allonger le travail sur la durée de la
vie ni sur la semaine folle réduire faut
faire 32 eur et 60 ans parce que comme
ça il y aura un partage du travail et y
aura date du boulot pour les jeunes
l'idée même de repousser l'âge de la
retraite alors qu'on nous annonce
pratiquement un million de chômeurs dans
les mois qui viennent peut-être deux
millions de plus et qu'on est déjà assez
millions 600 mille schaub à nous
annoncer ça nous dire vous allez
travailler plus sur la semaine vous
allez travailler plus sur la vie et
aggraver le chômage c'est le choix
contraire à celui qu'il faut faire faut
réduire la durée du travail sur la
semaine et sur la vie alors je passe
filoche j'ai un fils la méthode du
premier ministre est une méthode de
dialogue et d'écouté ce sont les mots à
de bruno lemaire chez nos confrères de
rtl
est ce que finalement avec jean castex
la réforme a plus de chances d'aboutir
dans l'apaisement plutôt qu'avec edouard
philippe selon vous
aucune aucune n'y a pas d'hésitation sur
ce plan là il y aura pas d'acceptabilité
plus avec un texte qu avec edouard
philippe
et là il y aura pas plus de négociation
tout le monde sait les positions des uns
et des autres pourquoi inventer ce
système par points que personne comprend
mais québec est négatif pour quoi
remettre en cause notre retraite alors
qu'elle large
on a combien il disait avant macro n'y a
pas d'argent caché on y vient trouver
430 milliards à donner aux entreprises
et quand c'est les entreprises c'est pas
les salariés 1 sur les actionnaires et
les chefs d'entreprise les salariés ils
se font licencier puisque cet argent est
donné aux chefs d'entreprise et vos
actionnaires sans condition et que les
actionnaires on sait bien tout ce qu'ils
font ils vont mettre l'argent dans les
îles caïmans ou bien en cours ou bien
ailleurs
et le met pas dans nos caisses de
retraite un mois je propose linverse
c'est que cet argent il est aux salaires
on augmente les salaires parce que quand
on augmente les salaires on augmente la
part socialisée du salaire le salaire
brut et dont pour fourni de l'argent
pour nos caisses de retraite et ont
fourni de l'argent pour notre santé et
on est capable de faire face aux crises
sanitaires à la protection sociale et à
la pauvreté grâce à ça et ce
gouvernement charest même pas à
comprendre comment il peut en pleine
crise sanitaire inachevé comment ils
poussent s'engager dans une telle
provocation sur les retraites
une telle brutalité pourquoi pour avoir
raison et disent qu'il faut pas qu'ils
reculent mais macron il y laisse à ses
options projet c'est de supprimer les
cotisations sociales
c'est ce qu'il a dit à deux ans circule
j'espère en tout cas qui reculent ce qui
supprime les cotisations sociales
on est tous n'y aura pas d'argent pour
nos hôpitaux pour nos médecins pour nous
au soir en plus de ne pas avoir de
retraite dans 60 ans pour ceux qui
seront encore là pour en discuter
il ya quelque chose d'aberrant dans le
fanatisme idéologique à vous à passer en
force sur cette question là par tous les
bouts leur église mais on va on va
trouver de l'argent quand même alors la
crds
elle devait s'arrêter en 2009 ils l'ont
reportée jusqu'en 2024
puis en de v33 il parle maintenant de la
reporter jusqu'en 2042
donc ils vont faire un impôt c'est un ds
sur le salaire qui qui en fait
rembourser des dettes c'est un transfert
des dettes de notre budget social au
trou du budget de l'état c'est aussi
aussi incroyable et je répète ma
conduisait qui a pas d'argent caché
m'enfin ils ont trouvé les centaines de
milliards alors laden et la dette
elle sera jamais remboursé ce qui nous
font croire que la dette soit remboursée
sont deux sont des illusionnistes
et c'est la filoche on saura rien à
l'économie et nos retraites défendu avec
choeur par tous ceux qu'ils m'entendent
on la scène et on dit merci beaucoup
gérard filoche d'avoir accepté de
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien inspecteur du travail